You're a student of the game.
If Aaron Judge hits
62 home runs or more,
is he the authentic
home run champion?
(CHUCKLES) Oh, man.
That is a very tough question.
I-- You know, I think...
You know, we just touched on it.
Just the history of this game,
there's so much history.
I think it's really hard
to compare eras.
And that Barry Bonds era
is a unique distinction
in this game.
The Roger Maris before that
was a different time as well.
I mean, you put Roger Maris
into today's game,
or Babe Ruth in today's game
with everybody coming out
of the bull pen,
throwing 100 miles an hour,
you know, who knows what
they're able to accomplish?
So I think we need
to really appreciate
what Judge is doing right now
in this era, on his own.
I mean, it's...
I think it's...
You know, I think there's
two separate numbers, though.
You know, there's Roger's
and there's Barry's.
And I think
to be able to reach Maris',
I think, should be celebrated
because the '90s era was just
a different era of baseball.
It's live ball.
You have a live-ball era,
a dead-ball era, a steroid era,
whatever era it is.
But it's really fun to see
what he's able to do,
and bring attention
to this game.
You know,
that's what it's all about.
So I can't really answer
that question,
but I think it should
definitely be celebrated
if he passes Maris' record.